when you see somebody work on kubernetes
for the first time and they realize what
it's actually capable of doing and they
get this this spark of like wow that was
really amazing that was that was
incredible I didn't know I could do that
that moment is what keeps me going
covering IDs is a container management
platform it's an open source if you have
a collection of machines you can package
up your applications in containers and
give it to kubernetes and run it for you
well it gives developers is actually the
luxury of not caring about the
infrastructure kubernetes on its own is
taking care of monitoring logging
scaling and other things that are
required in order managing applications
in production at scale kubernetes the
word stands for helmsman kubernetes is
that system that makes sure that your
applications are always afloat and
always accessible in a sea of resources
that is the cloud it was really critical
in my opinion to open source kubernetes
so Google started the project based on
what we knew about how things work
inside of Google but having contributors
like Red Hat and others allowed us
actually figure out how to make it work
for the outside world and that was a key
to success for kubernetes we really
needed to think about the adoption what
the customers will know all the users so
originally we really were focusing on
ease of use in documentation and
understanding like what is their
familiarity in order for them to use the
technology about six months of work we
delivered something of value to external
customers gke is probably the best
production ready kubernetes install you
can get you click a single button in
about five minutes we'll give you this
production ready cluster but full
lifecycle management so what we're
trying to do is take gke and packaged up
and anthos and give you the ability to
do the same thing on print and even
other cloud providers we move from a
standard processing to a microservices
processing and without kubernetes there
was no way to do that it's an open
source so it was important for us not to
be glued in a provider so now in our on
premise we are deploying kubernetes
ourselves and on GCP were using DK
kubernetes is everywhere it's being used
by your bank your retailer your pizza
shop Pizza Hut uses kubernetes to run a
large portion of
our e-commerce services and
infrastructure it's extremely important
for us that our services be available
when our customers want to purchase food
from us kubernetes has impacted our
business by giving us just a really
great fast
speed to market on delivering technology
we made the migration from Asher to GCP
we did it for a couple major reasons
first off the quality of engineering on
GCP the second piece is really big with
kubernetes like we our development
company we're all about helping people
right the next thing they want to build
and that's gonna be done in Coober days
the future of kubernetes it's very
similar to what infrastructure are doing
for Google developers we want to empower
developers everywhere to innovate
without leaning to care about
infrastructure all problems we already
solved for them and you we started
seeing some parts of those kind of
things really amazing innovation what
people are using kubernetes for and I
expect you to see more and more amazing
ideas and how software is really
changing the world yeah I can't believe
I'm talking to software but happy
Anniversary kubernetes happy birthday to
kubernetes the project and the community
and thank you so much to the thousands
of people who make my life it's very
very exciting happy fifth anniversary
kubernetes you continue to inspire and
amaze